si monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur laurent first monsieur le
premier ministre ma question est simple
le gouvernement at il conscience de la
dégradation du réseau routier français
le réseau routier constitue un
patrimoine considérable qui permet
d'assurer 88 % des déplacements des
français
pourtant aujourd'hui ce réseau vieillit
ce réseau s'abîme et devient même
parfois dangereux
il ya d'abord le réseau national certes
les 9000 kilomètres d'autoroute concédée
sont entretenus mais il y à l'édile
12000 km de routes nationales pour
lesquelles vous ne consacrer que 243
millions d'euros à la régénération des
chaussées des ouvrages d'art les
départements entretiennent 380 mille
kilomètres de routes mais les
départements de france sont à l'agonie
financières n'ayant pas réussi à les
faire disparaître vouloir imposer un
garrot budgétaire qui rend bien des
conseils départementaux incapable
d'entretenir leur route
il ya enfin le réseau communal 660 1000
km tous les maires de france tente
d'entretenir leur route
mais la baisse de 30 % des dotations
d'état aux collectivités se traduit par
un effondrement du volume des travaux
qui dans bien des arbitrages sont remis
au lendemain
un réseau routier mal entretenu est un
réseau routier qui se dégrade
lorsque les travaux d'entretien sont
reportés les coûts progressent de
manière exponentielle
la situation des routes françaises va
rapidement devenir critique et cela est
le fruit de vos choix
avez vous seulement mesurer les
conséquences de votre politique en terme
de sécurité routière d'image de la
france et de destructions d'emplois dans
le secteur des travaux publics
l'effondrement de l'investissement des
collectivités locales va rapidement
avoir des conséquences sérieuses ce
quinquennat laissera une bombe à
retardement celle de l'altération
prononcé de nos routes patrimoine
collectif est essentielle à la vie de
tous les français comme au
fonctionnement de notre économie
merci d'abord l'état monsieur alain
vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député sur le constat de l'état du
réseau routier français
le gouvernement peut partager vos
préoccupations simplement vous admettrez
avec lui que on n'a pas observé de
dégradation continue de et subite depuis
trois ans et qui gala le résultat je
dirais de choix qui ont été faits depuis
longtemps probablement par tout le monde
et qui justifie pleinement votre votre
question le gouvernement a essayé d'y
apporter des réponses d'abord pour ce
qui est de sa responsabilité et sa
responsabilité première c'est
naturellement la qualité du réseau
national le réseau concédé je veux quand
même rappeler l'accord qui est intervenu
vous le savez 3 milliards de travaux qui
vont être faits par les sociétés
concessionnaires c'est extrêmement
important pour avoir un niveau
autoroutier qui soient satisfaisants
mais aussi sur le réseau propre
le réseau national qui lui dépend dépend
de l'état et sur ce réseau vous le savez
conscient de ces difficultés et malgré
les contraintes budgétaires
le premier ministre a en 2015 annoncé un
programme
il fait exécuter un programme
exceptionnel ce programme d'entretien de
100 millions qui a été entièrement
exécutés dans l'année 2015 toutes les
opérations sont en ligne sur le site de
mon ministère je peux vous indiquer que
le premier ministre a souhaité que nour
et engageront une réflexion de cette
même nature pour 2016 ça aboutit à
doubler les crédits en ce qui concerne
l'entretien
s'agissant ensuite des travaux des
collectivités locales nous avons eu
souvent des discussions avec elles dans
le cadre notamment des contrats de plan
et vous savez bien qu'ici la volonté des
élus est la volonté de l'état c'est
souvent rencontrés parce que le
programme routier notamment est au
rendez vous de ces contrats de plan état
région il ya donc un vrai effort et une
volonté partagée d'améliorer l'état du
réseau
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame vas tu